we are excited about turning to our next
guest actors in Hollywood power couple
and I do me power couple dulay Hill and
Jasmine Simon Hill is known for his
roles and TV shows like The West Wing
psych and The Wonder Years Simon is an
author and actor best known for her role
on the TV show Ballers and that is
actually where they met here's a scene
with their characters at a tense dinner
take a look
amen amen and sweet baby Jesus please
shine thy Grace on these two proud
strong men and light the path to
forgiveness understanding and love amen
amen
now the couple and parents of two have
written a children's book called repeat
after me big things to say every day
it's filled with encouraging
affirmations that parents can share with
their kids including phrases like I am
worthy I am enough I am important Doula
Hill and Jasmine Simon are here good
morning how are you doing good morning
to you all as well all is well thank you
for joining us all is well and today is
your birthday it is my birthday
thank you thank you I appreciate it
we brought you nothing but ourselves you
see and it's a wonderful gift you know
what I mean his birthday too so you see
what I'm saying that's that's right your
son me and James Brown
[Applause]
let's talk about this book okay we're
celebrating your birthday we're
celebrating this book why didn't you
think it was important to write a book
like this well I always got to pass it
off to my beautiful wife to answer that
question uh I'll quickly say I will
quickly say that it's important to you
we want to create space there's so much
negativity in the world and we thought
that if we could just plant some seeds
of goodness some seeds of light some
seeds of Joy let people be able to
receive themselves for the fullness of
who they are then maybe they can honor
that that gift that's inside other
people it's a little step to hopefully
be able to just make a a better
community and a better world but Jasmine
you always answer better than that well
I mean I think he summed it up just
right when you had to come about though
Jasmine so in 2020 we all know what
happened in 2020 we had a brand new
virus that was killing people thousands
every day and in June we saw George
Floyd get murdered on TV and we had a 12
month old at a time at the time and a 15
year old and we thought to ourselves I
thought what is our son thinking when he
sees this he's absorbing something what
is Kennedy thinking when she sees this
and I turned a dulay and I said we need
our kids to know that they are not the
worst that they see on TV that they are
the very best and we need to write a
book and do they looked at me and said
you're giving words to her as she's
going to school so from the age of two
years old when she started preschool I
started affirmations I read somewhere
that when you say affirmations in out
loud in first person that you can
actually rewire your brain to believe
the things that you're saying so I knew
that I had a little girl and I wanted to
her to love herself and so at two years
old we start saying these affirmations
and so from the age of 2 till 16 when
she learned how to drive we did them
every single day how did you decide on
the affirmations you were going to
include in the book dulay because my
favorite is I am ready you are filled
with strength love and might boldly go
forth and Shine Your Light I love that
how did you decide what affirmations to
include there's there were so many
affirmations that we all finished and it
really was about paring it down to see
which ones were really uh risk that
children could receive because I know we
tried to stay away from things that were
very subjective subjective gotcha do you
have a favorite my favorite is I'm
enough I'm enough
how many times have you heard that
growing up that you're deserving me very
little and I think that if I would have
heard that that I would have believed in
myself more who knows what I would have
been able to do more than what I've done
spaces more confident absolutely because
I know I deserved to be there that's
right yes you two just celebrated your
fifth anniversary together yeah
uh what else do you think makes the
relationship work
communication oh my God communication is
key I think always thinking about the
other person I always say if I'm
thinking about me and you're thinking
about me that's not going that can only
last for so long if you're thinking
about you and I'm thinking about you
that can only last for so long but if
you're thinking about me and I'm
thinking about you then we can always
hold each other up that's always the
philosophy that I tried I mean that's
why I married him because he's a
philosopher like he thinks of things but
yes communication and always thinking
about one another marriage is hard and
people don't tell people that like you
have a fairy tale you have a wedding you
think that's it that's not it that's a
really bad part it's just the beginning
that's a party so many people Michelle
Obama said but she said I didn't like
Barack for about 10 years even if she
would have quit then she would have lost
out on 20. I I heard that and I thought
that is really poignant and important
because I'm gonna remind you that next
time yeah get mad remember like no
matter what Michelle said
Michelle
she's preaching this morning because I
got a text from my wife
oh that's funny
it's always right you know marriages go
through it and he does and her whole
thing was about
there will be times where I don't like
you but this is what she said to me I've
never forgotten Barack Obama has never
disappointed her on the things that
truly matter in a relationship and in
marriage and I think that's very key
right I think this book though guys is
so good that I think adults could
benefit from it too I love how you end
with now repeat after me and you go
through I am worthy love deserving
cherished unique don't you think adults
could also benefit from this put some
adults oh yes don't you Nate that's a
duality right yeah the children will
hear it but the parents and caregivers
have to say it you know when they say it
they don't know that we're kind of
tricking them because we are also
rewiring their brains to believe the
things that they're saying so their
children get to hear it and repeat it
the adults get to say it and believe it
and the children also get to see their
parents or caregivers caring about their
own self-worth and can emulate that in
their lives nicely done is there a
couple's book coming next about marriage
going to write sit and invites me to be
on the journey then I will
but your greatest work is what you guys
do off camera no thank you so much for
joining us
Jasmine Simon we appreciate you repeat
after me is on sale now